out of all the places you've been
out of all the places you've been what's
your number one where you say
if money is not an issue if i want to
take my friends if i want to go to a
place and sit down and enjoy food my
number one is dot dot dot what is that
place for you
oh my gosh um
that's a very difficult question to
answer and i would answer it differently
today than i did a couple years ago
a couple years ago i might have
said something like you know let's go
and do the vegetarian tasting menu at
arpeggio in paris
let's go to one of the three star
michelin
uh restaurants in tokyo right let
let's go and really celebrate in the in
the private room
at you know uh a linea and tell them to
really put on the feed bag for us right
i mean
just to have that over the top
experience i love that kind of dining
i truly do because i love seeing what a
chef can do
that kind of chef at the peak of his
powers with ingredients the
transformational
things that they do with food the the
techniques that are going to be used 30
years later once it
trickles down to you know home cooking
but i think what's most what's notable
and powerful
for me are the places where i can
share more food with more people
on the island of palawan in the
philippines
there's a a bunch of floating
restaurants
you you some are at the end of a dock
they've built a rickety dock
half mile out into the water there's i
wrote about one in in my first book you
know a place where i can go
where the fishermen come in and they
they they lift the
fish and the shellfish and the malice
up into the center of the restaurant
through a big hole cut in the middle of
it
the restaurant is on stilts in the water
where you can watch the sun go down
where you're sitting on the water
where the bananas for frozen banana
drinks are cut from a giant
ripe banana plant that was tree ripened
that's sitting by the bar
where the limes are grown in the
backyard of someone's house and picked
and brought in
where everything is so fresh and so
simple and it's really a matter of
whether you want your
fish or shellfish you know grilled raw
or sauteed that's the only way we do it
pick your poison those the kind of
places that really thrill me the most it
has as much to do with location
and simplicity of food as it does
uh with the quality of what's being
cooked because i think the quality now
means something different to me
um i've seen all the pyrotechnics i've
seen all the fancy stuff
um you know you talked about cartagena
in medellin there's uh
a polo carbon you know charcoal roasted
chicken is
what's eaten every street has a
different pile carbon
place but there are a couple that do it
a lot better than the others
right you know give me a good polar
carbon
place and a lot of really cold frosty
root beer
and 30 of my closest friends and let us
just sit there for hours and get
messy with our fingers eating poi carbon
uh going out into the street and buying
a sugar cane juice with lime and mint
crushed with it
i'm happy as a clam there last night i
shooting an episode of family dinner i i
was eating with the nigerian family
and uh they they did a version of
burning meat on skewers something that
all over africa you go into
neighborhoods and it's just
people build a fire throw a grill on top
of it and you can actually pick your cut
typically the animal is
there being butchered on the back table
and you can point and say i want a
little
shoulder i want a little luxury cut
because everything costs a different
price
right they they know the luxury cuts are
more expensive than cuts from the
the leg or the tendon or the neck or the
cheek um
and you know you sit there and you order
it same thing in the
you know jamal finna in marrakech you
know in the sook there
where with lamb it's the same you order
them and they pull a little bit
from different parts of the animal and
they put it on a piece of newspaper and
they spill a little bit of
cumin chili and salt mixture on the
plate for you to season your own lamb
with and you eat it with your fingers
and if you want bread
they send a kid around the corner to the
bread place and he comes back with that
and some
hot or cold mint tea i i'd rather eat in
a place like that
almost if if you said andrew
lets you and i go to one place for
dinner tonight
anywhere in the world it might
be to some of the markets that i've been
to
in small villages jungle markets in the
vietnamese countryside
where spring rolls and grilled fish and
shrimp salads and just just
the food that you just you want to just
keep eating for the rest
of your life you pinch yourself it's so
good as being made fresh
i remember being in uh isaan thailand up
in the north on the
laotian border just about 30 miles from
vientiane but about five eight miles in
from the laotian border and i was on a
farm
and they told me that they were gonna
make uh a shrimp salad a drunken shrimp
salad for dinner
and i knew that you know you take the
small shrimp and they're live and you
drown them in rice wine and then you mix
it with
toasted rice powder and chili and ginger
and garlic and
fish sauce and sugar and mint and
cilantro and crushed peanuts and
tomatoes
and you have those just fantastic shrimp
salad it's one of my favorite dishes
uh in the vietnamese vietnamese culinary
cannon
and grandma went down to the river with
her net and started taking these
freshwater shrimp
out of the out of the river
i don't think i'd eaten anything that
good you know i would put that dish
up against anything that i've eaten
anywhere on planet earth
right um food is not just about
the expense you know that's why the
caviar conversation used to make me
uncomfortable
um and i have it freely with people
where i have the opportunity to explain
it
because the fact of the matter is is
that the food that i find
is the most precious is the stuff that's
only available on what i call the last
stop on the subway
the further away you have to go to get
it the more
valuable it is a year ago if you and i
want to have a great meal in new york
right i mean between the two of us we
can call up friends we can get into any
restaurant we want as a deuce right
we'll eat at the bar
we'll have an amazing meal the chef will
throw all kinds of free stuff at it
the bartender will keep us happy and
we're gonna have a good time you and i
any restaurant but what we can't do is
be out in a village in
botswana with a big fat yellow african
moon rising up over the aha hills while
a goat is slowly roasting over the fire
while people are playing the same music
that their ancestors played for 40
000 years we can't how do we we can't
buy that that's the precious experience
that i got to have for 14 years on the
road making bizarre foods and other
shows
that i miss